good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all the major problems of the
world today's message is don't quit over
to you Colonel Sanders
[Music]
I was workin for a livin I operated
restroom for about 25 years and trying
to serve the best food that I had served
to the public that's where I developed
my chicken recipe that I wanted to have
the best chicken in my restaurant a
nanny competitor had solely I was on the
highway where they go to Florida or to
Smoky Mountains and I was they went down
to there I want to get them as they come
back and you'd find out surprising how
long after they forgot all about the
price of the food before putting forth
the quality come back again for that
good food
I was listed with Duncan Hines and
ventures a good eating and I gave me a
very select clientele to I had a moral
obligation to give people something good
something worthwhile
and I loved it now you come along
surveyed this interstate system a 27
mile back immediately sometime dry I was
66 years old I couldn't afford to quit
of course when they were talking about
it for three or four years before look
like I'm going to be a reality I've
begun to put on a guinea pig franchise
because I was thinking what can I do
next they're gonna wipe out this
restaurant and I thought well I tried to
franchise the chicken so by getting four
or five these guinea pig franchises I
proved to myself I had a product would
take with the public profitable to the
restaurant man and also it really go was
just very writer getting behind it and
can put over good so one is did serve in
the system I was left something behind
right so that wiped me out
mmm isn't that you know here's a case
where disaster really was a blessing
something that could have could have
destroyed you God turned it around
really I think sometimes people think
that you know you
stead of laying down and dying when
Astor comes you can use it as stepping
stone it's a great home for something
else there's no question about that so
my question was what could I save out of
that rectus these are going to be
wrecked and the chicken was taken as
proving is taken with the public and all
I had to say waiting it in going I think
tomorrow my life is don't quit in 65
maybe your boat hasn't come in yet see
man so I love the storm Colonel Sanders
is one of my favorite stores and
examples to give of an older
entrepreneur this guy didn't really
start franchising his business KFC until
he was in his 60s and didn't really
become an icon or someone super
well-known until he was in his seventies
how many people quit too soon under
business I can't tell you how many
people come up to me and say Evan I'm 25
years old
is it too late to get started like what
are you talking about and really just
comes down to just your belief system he
was a guy who was 62 years old when he
was franchising KFC where a lot of
people would be saying I'm getting ready
to retire I'm getting ready to slow down
I'm getting ready to wine things up you
know just ease into the rest of my life
and it was a guy who said no I'm gonna
I'm going to crush it I'm just getting
started I want to build an empire right
and this really comes down to whether
you believe it can happen or it can
happen you're right if you believe at 62
years old that you're too old to get
start on something new then you're right
and you will take action but if you
believe that age is just a number and 62
means you've got lots of experience and
you're ready to go crush some new
project then you're right as well and so
you should be really careful to pay
attention to the story that you're
telling yourself because a lot of times
we're holding ourselves back with these
excuses of we're too old or too young we
come from the wrong country we know the
right education you know the right
parents on and on and on and as long as
you believe that reinforcing story then
it's going to continue to perpetuate
now in terms of don't quitting there's a
lot of advice you don't quit don't quit
don't quit don't quit you should not
quit when it's your dream when this is
something that you really really
I really want to do then you can't quit
on it but if it's something that you
lost the passion for you don't feel
energized by it anymore
it feels like work to show up then
that's when you quit and some people ask
me should I quit this thing or not well
is it still your dream are you still
passionate about it you're still excited
about it because if you are then you
enjoy the process and yes you want to
get the results and yes you want to win
and yes you want to make the money yes
what I have that impact but you still
enjoy the process
I'd like making YouTube videos this is
fun for me it's enjoyable for me I'm
growing through it and even if I wasn't
on the path of hitting a million
subscribers I would still be doing it
because I love doing it and if I was on
the path that he's a million subscribers
and I stopped liking it then I would
leave I would sell it I would go do
something else because you cannot do
great things when you don't love what
you do and so as long as it's still your
passion as long as it's still your dream
you have to keep going or you're going
to live the rest of your life in regret
if you've lost our passions and get out
immediately and go do something else it
does bring you excitement joy energy
filming so the question today is I'm
curious what is the story that you have
historically told yourself as to why you
can't be successful like I'm too old
what is the store that you have
consistently told yourself in the past
we're going to shed it now it's gone
after today what has that story been
leaving the comments below super curious
to find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to John Miller crew jr. John
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the read thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself a whatever here one word is
much love and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shots of
espresso
[Music]
so unfortunate a lot of people stand in
front of the stove of life and they say
now stove you give me some heat and I'll
put some food in you that ain't the way
it works you got to put something in
before you can get anything out so many
times you know the employee goes to the
employer and say give me raise then I'll
start coming to work on time
all right so many times they will come
to him and say maybe the boss now I know
I haven't been here very long don't
really deserve to be long but I just
function better when I am in charge of
Inc you reward me now and then I promise
you I'll learn what this business is all
about later on reward me now and I'll
produce later doesn't work that way
can't you just see a youngster in school
saying teacher if I take a failing grade
home my parents going to skin me alive
pass me on this quarter and next time
I'll study more than anybody else reward
me now I'll produce later it doesn't
work that way can't you just see an old
farmer standing out in the fields in
October and said Lord I know I didn't
plan to clean this year but if you give
me a big crop this year I'll plant more
than anybody next year it ain't that way
folks you gotta put something in before
you can expect to get anything out well
it doesn't pump it away you know that's
hot it's August I mean the question is
it how much pumping are you going to do
Parker I drink the water and finally oh
Bernard said you know Jimmy I don't
believe it's in the water down there
Jimmy said yeah it is Bernard you know
in South Alabama the wells are deep it
all we're glad they're deep because the
deeper the well the cooler the cleaner
the sweet of the pure the better tasting
the water and isn't that true of length
intuitive that if you can become an MD
by six weeks of summer school that the
rewards would be almost minimal or
nothing and how many paces would you
have ended sure that if you become a
sales expert in three days of a training
school well that the rate of pay would
go down rather radically isn't it true
that anything worth doing is worth doing
pearly until you can learn to do it well
we'll never know how many kids have
missed a college scholarship because
they didn't study an average of ten more
minutes a day we will never know how we
come so close to promotion but we're
good discouraged and quit too soon we'll
never know how much more success we
would have had
had we just had a little more pumping in
there and pump and pump and pump in
truck well finally Oh Bernard just got
disgusted through booze and you said
Jimmy there's just no water down there
difference that don't stop my eyes don't
touch if you something what is going to
go all the way back down and then you're
going to have to start all over the
reality is folks and I'm totally
convinced of this this is the story of
America this is your story this is the
story of success this is the story of
life I believe with all of my heart that
if you would pump long enough and hard
enough and enthusiastically enough but
eventually the reward is going to follow
the effort and then once that water
starts to flow all you got to do is just
keep the steady pressure on it and
you're going to get more water than you
can possibly use the basic problem is
this so many times people get involved
in something and they'll say well I'll
give it a try and if it works out
that'll be good and is it if it doesn't
work out I mean hang on Kelly Chad you
know what I mean fellas I gotta tell you
some folks you're going to pump forever
like that before anything happens when
you get into something grab that sucker
and get with it and then once the water
starts to flow then ladies and gentlemen
that's what strategies for success is
all about here's an important point
nothing works the first time when you
try something new it probably won't work
when you try something new several times
it probably won't work and when the
turning point in my life came when I
would hear good ideas and I was so eager
to be successful in selling I would run
out and try the ideas and they wouldn't
work I try a way of getting an
appointment or answering an objection or
closing a sale it wouldn't work and my
natural response ah and I think yes to
be disappointed and then I realized
nothing works at least the first few
times so I decided I would try a new
idea five or ten times before I pass
judgment on I would not just try it once
and quit like most people do and that
changed my whole life it was a turning
point in my life because I realized from
then on if you've got a good idea and
you've got a good goal and you want to
double your income and improve the
quality of your life and you have to try
new things in order to get new results
it's not going to work the first time
since a well if I didn't work try
something else and try something else
and try something else
now if you try
only two things can happen what are they
succeed or fail if you succeed you do
more of it if you fail you learn from it
get smarter and try it again so you
cannot lose by taking action you can
only lose by not taking action so but
why didn't you still believe in the
company I mean I have to think that at
any point in Silicon Valley history
there's a lot of people that at that
point they're just like this isn't going
to work
markets changed this isn't a viable
concept anymore well you know I I I
don't know how much belief I had but I
knew that I had kind of gotten everybody
into the boat with me so it wasn't so
much that I didn't want to quit I wanted
to quit every day it was in that job I
felt like throwing up when I woke up in
the morning
you know what it's like having a baby
now yeah exactly like I felt like I was
pregnant but you know I'd hired every
employee and they all trust me I'd raise
all the money I talked every investor
into putting their money and I had given
stock to you know like my friends and
relatives and they were all excited
about the prospects for the company when
it went public like a lot of my friends
from high school like bought the stock
because I was running the company and so
I just I felt like I could die but I
can't quit and you know one of the
horrible things about being founder CEO
is it's the one job you really can't
quit or if you do quit your Punk so you
know I didn't want to be a punk so I I
just kept you know I just kept pedaling
but it was rough I mean like that was a
running sloughed cloud and it's right
and it didn't stop there right like does
loud cloud yeah loud cloud you know by
the time loud cloud was two-and-a-half
years old I had like sold like the loud
cloud part of the business and I had to
change it into another business so like
that the next thing that happened was
right loud pod was going to go bankrupt
so I raised 160 million dollars in the
IPO so like I burned you know like we
burnt through that and we can't stop the
burn because the customer
kept going out of business and so like
we were headed towards bankruptcy so
then I had to you know I sold the
services part of the business and all
the cash burn TDs and then I had to
layoff you know probably you know
another third of the employees and then
I kept the remaining 80 employees and we
became a software company a publicly
traded software company with no
customers in a revenue which was an
another g-train opt where that's when we
became ops where yeah so like that was
hard but it was good you know it that
kind of stuff it makes you strong you
know eventually you know we through five
years later we sold to hila Packard for
you know 1.6 billion dollars and not a
bad accent which was like still and
still shocked by the whole thing I still
wake up in the middle of the night going
are we're going to run out of money